damit der damen hollywood wasser hat
vorjahr
murats ernsthaft herzlich willkommen bei
moratti häufigsten richtig geniale
spread und zwar zwischen genie und mir
mensch gegen maschine künstliche
intelligenz gegen plankton hier herzlich
willkommen juli sie kennt die
einwanderungsbehörde kent wells in der
tod kennt ihn mehr ist plankl niemand in
sachsen und menschen die maschine
plankton gegen künstliche intelligenz
das plankton ich dich du weiter
so gehören cooles battle und soll man
was ganz ganz einfaches und und zwar
machen wir uns stellen und zwar eins
rudel und zwar waren wir zwei
verschiedene schule und süße varianten
wie der kunde das gemerkt und wir machen
eine richtig geniale herzhafte variante
und nachher lass mir irgendjemand im
haus finden probieren und der verlierer
war der verlierer der zauber der macht
sauber ja also du machst seien auf jeden
fall ein ganz einfaches rezept was wir
natürlich brauchen ist als allererstes
einen blätterteig und da wird es sie
nicht unnötig in die länge ziehen
möchten haben wir uns einen fertigen
blätterteig geholt einmal für mich und
einmal für juni tun das nicht hätten
damals intel im blätterteig haben wir
sind nicht sehr lieb und deswegen haben
wir den fertigen geholt sagt wenn er
diesen teil gehabt gibt es die ganz
einfach wer diesen tag ihr habt macht
das hat doch erst übernommen die
wahrheit nein sowie ein klappen so
doppelt ok also warte jetzt stimmt es
okay auf jeden fall einmal klappen und
dann weiter sag' erzählst du mal dass
sie das duo schneider ja schneidest hier
einen radius gramm
und radios hat niemand welchen winkel
diesen hat ich meine ja wie viel grad
hatten hatten halber ein viertel kreis
90 und rechte winkel hat auch 90 also
ich das gleiche das war schon mein gott
das gibt's doch gar nicht auf jeden fall
machen wir das um die ecken einfach so
rund zu machen weil es so was wie das
studio soll ein wie ein schiff hinaus
sind so damals auch ich zeige es auch
ich mag es ein bisschen professioneller
als der winter das habt ihr hier diese
schiffchen jetzt kommt was genial dass
das zeige ich euch und zwar hier
los angeles ich kann es nur einmal
machen das ist das passiert nur einmal
und wenn da nicht dabei bist dann passt
es nicht nochmal so aber nicht komplett
durch schneiden sondern hier wieder
ansetzen und wieder die technik zu
beachten die technik so geschwitzt und
jetzt kommt was richtig genial ist jetzt
passt man auch was ich mache
[Musik]
ich hasse sie übertreiben müssen eine
karte ok jetzt kommt patrick erzählt
euch wahrscheinlich wenn er bis jetzt
macht hätten euch von den richtigen
coolen bäcker oder meisten kocht und
zwar jetzt nimmt er ein paar eier pizza
rat ihr könnt auch ein messer nehmen wir
könnten zahnstocher nehmen und jetzt
macht ihr hier so kleine kerben rein
weil wenn der teig nachher hier am rand
hörbar zieht es richtig aus als hätte
das eingeflochten aber sich nur ein
trick
so jetzt habe ich es eingeschnitten und
jetzt tut es einfach einstreichen
haltung und ein nein ich hole 3
jetzt haben sie ein geniales
eingestellten wir haben diese
verfärbungen rein gemacht und jetzt
nicht mehr dieses hier jetzt passt mal
auf jetzt tue das nicht bestreiten
bestreichen dann bekommt so schönen
glanz dahinter bitte ein ganzes das
heißt weiß plus eigelb folgendes jetzt
habe ich mit eingestrichen und jetzt
gucke ich wirklich dass diese zweite
schicht richtig schön windig drauf sitzt
und jetzt tue ich ihnen drin noch mal so
leicht einschneiden
damit ist auch richtig hoch geht das
heißt leicht einschneiden idiot ab
durchgeschnitten so blöd so wie es jetzt
gemacht habt dann tut es einfach hoffen
vor allem dass jeder backofen ist
verschieden das heißt was bei mir
vielleicht fünf minuten sein kann nur
zehn minuten sein kann kann bräuchen für
zehn oder zwanzig sein konnten darauf an
deswegen einfach so ein bisschen
goldbraun ist einfach im backofen
schieben wir ja leicht an bräunt genau
dann wenn man hier zb sagt es ist
einfach kurz den backofen einfach bei
190 3 mittlere ebene mittlere schiene zu
machen und statt und einfach wenn es ein
bisschen gold braunisch wieder rausholen
und was belegen und wenn das belegt
haben dann schieben das nochmal recht
ganz wichtig man kann ja auch mal fehler
zeigen
er ist mein größter fehler das ist der
zweite fehler und zwar der zweite täter
ist ganz einfach im blätterteig oben
immer ein stück media nicht einsteckt
dann geht es hoch wie so ein ballon das
heißt ganz kurz bevor ein schiebt ein
stechen so sehr dass sich jetzt einfach
kurz ein bisschen ein stechen das nicht
hochgeht
so werden unsere blätterteig das tut
schon mal vor backen bis sie goldgelb
sind mir schon mal unsere füllung
vorbereiten also nichts sage ich mal
herzhaft der knie macht süßware belag
genau und ich habe euch auch keine
zutaten denn nimmt einfach alles was den
kühlschrank haben das heißt es genau der
bühne ganz ganz wichtig der grund ich
eigentlich hier das mangement genau wie
beim flammkuchen auch
ich habe hirschmann den könnte überall
kaufen im supermarkt dann habe ich noch
im kühlschrank ein bisschen schnittlauch
gefundene finde ich auch richtig cool
dann habe ich bis jetzt keine
produktplatzierung kein geld natürlich
mag denn unheimlich das ist gaza krise
das ist ein café keese der kommt auch
ein der sorgt immer für eine richtig
coole cremige konsistenz und der ist
selber nicht zu mächtig also der käse
ist nicht so mächtig dass er nachher zb
meine wurst übertönt
dann habe ich nummer was von gaza wieder
keine produktplatzierung ich mag mein
akku ist mein lieblings muss ich sagen
das ist ein normaler käse da gibt es
eine gewisse würze mit rich man auf
jeden fall richtig cool und was ich
natürlich auch wie mache ich tun noch
hier habe ich noch ein bisschen salami
im kühlschrank gefunden
die zuschauer noch ein nein ist es
renault salami und die instrumente alles
was ich auch habe ist hier noch drauf
machen
das gibt die besondere würze das ist
passt sagt es ist ein wiesbaden
hergestellt ist ein richtig cooler
wie passt rahmen passt ja pastrana ist
ein rinderstall mit bockshornklee
außenrum war es gegen richtig geschmack
und während ich das grad alles erzählt
habe habe ich gemerkt dass hier die was
ihr mund zusammengelaufen
jetzt hab ich genau jetzt nehme ich
einfach hier
dem passt hier einfach und schneit dann
einfach ein bisschen auseinander und
wieder konnten wir ja er hat sich so
aufgefangen
mein gott das ihr weiters die immer so
was du bist fällt hier mal
sessionsauftakt dass ich meine du bist
du scheen geschnallt okay das nehmen wir
hier ich mag einfach ich sage dir
ehrlich ich mag einfach wurst unheimlich
[Musik]
so jetzt musst du die machen es erklärte
dazu macht man entspannt dann himbeeren
kochen und das land verteile und man
kommt noch und sind okay
und so macht schon zwar noch genügen
wenn man verhindern dass truppen
[Musik]
hier ergibt sich jetzt die himbeeren
einkochen
jetzt kommen dazu gar dazu wird schön da
gehört jetzt schon goldbraunen ich hole
jetzt unsere backbleche raus für mich
ich wollte auch kraus nicht dabei bin
dann mal gucken
das ist jetzt so weit fertig eingekocht
ich habe schon hier man sieht auch hier
schön goldbraun das reicht vollkommen
aus
und das ist auch das waren jetzt
insgesamt bei mir hat sich nur zehn
minuten gedauert haben vertrauen zu
hören genau sieht man an der an der
alten genau richtig so jetzt ganz ganz
einfach jetzt nämlich einfach nur
entspannt das macht jetzt hier drauf und
verteilt jetzt richtig schön und richtig
schön cremig muss man fallen tun
das muss jetzt auch gut aussehen also
das heißt neben fotos machen muss auch
schön sein
dann darfst du angriff auf die bilder
[Musik]
ein becher hat jetzt vollkommen gereicht
hier und jetzt nämlich richtig coolen im
belag und richtig schön verteilt und es
geht sei mäßig schnell ich glaube auch
dass es allgemein schneller geht als
pizza fans nicht geht jetzt natürlich
nach belieben noch ein bisschen pfeffer
wenig salz beides passt passt rami hat
schon sein eigenes ding nur ein bisschen
gerade wegen standbilder schmeißt auch
ziemlich neutral ist
[Musik]
so jetzt erst mal und to zoom einen
backofen vielleicht gerade ich tue schon
lange bis der käse richtig schönes
verschmolz nicht vielleicht auch weil
der baku ist schon heiß dann vielleicht
fünf minuten gehen vielleicht noch fünf
minuten
und darum muss raus und dann womöglich
eine unabhängige person die da probiert
und dann mal sehen wer hier der bessere
ist okay mensch gegen maschine
schließlich intelligenz gegen franck ok
einzeller rhein wieder bei 190 grad
[Musik]
das foto ist jetzt schon geschossen so
und jetzt muss es aber völlig fair sein
und nicht irgendwelche anspielungen
machen sagt ich hab das wird das gemacht
ok jetzt nur zwei leute holen zwar läuft
wie unparteiisch sind jetzt auch nicht
wissen was besser gemacht haben also
herzlich willkommen
sally und alex okay ihr probiert jetzt
und sagt jetzt müsse sich sagen jetzt
einiger süß herzhaft ihr probiert
einfach und sagt wenn es euch besser
geschmeckt hat aber eins kann man das
nicht vergleichen mit 11 die spielregel
mache ich sagen sind beide gut aus und
ich muss auch sagen ist extrem einfach
ist eine einfache resteverwertung
ich habe dieses zu teils extra
eingekauft wir hatten sie im kühlschrank
und damit die ganze zeit provoziert
nazis deswegen wäre dann der stadt immer
passt auch kein problem die stadt mag
ihre messer und werde jetzt durch das
arug nacken zu inspirieren tagen hatte
und für das an ruhigen anderes messer
damit den geschmack nicht verfälscht was
für ein zufall dass ich noch das neue
logo 14 wollte man habe zwar eine
produktplatzierung mein gott wir wollten
dann nehmen wir hier das ist schmeckt
selber aus wasser trinken denn geschmack
verfälschen
wie schmeckt auch gut prozent mannschaft
richtig gut drauf wer war s das
karamellisierter man sich ja eh schon
deinen gebrannten mandeln hacken und
dann noch drauf schreiben auf den
gedanken kommen eigentlich natürlich
nicht stimmt
ok man kann jetzt alles haben beides
gegessen jetzt eine ehrliche meinung was
hat euch jetzt besser gefallen nein
jetzt ja auch nicht es gibt nicht alle
haben die wohnung hauptsache es macht
spaß da rausgehen und gewinnen oder
verlieren
du hast verloren erster gang zwei tagen
ja ok wells gewonnen
ich kann optisch nicht sagen was ich
schön nach dem okay sie sich nicht mehr
alles mal ehrlich ich hab doch cool und
schmeckt oder nicht wird sich ja also da
gibt es doch zu also es war schön und
jetzt wäre es jetzt das kannst du papa
zu mir sagen auf jeden fall ganz klar
geworden welches zu geben möchten weil
sie morgen wie gegen mich sind alle drei
ich habe gewonnen
ok also ich hätte mir selber die hände
danke
hat spaß gemacht ich bin heute dazu
kommen aber auch so macht's gut
[Musik]